on dit que le charpentier est le plus
ancien des ouvriers du bâtiment jusqu'à
la révolution industrielle son métier
s'exerce exclusivement avec du bois il
peut travailler sur les églises les
monuments historiques les ponts les
bâtiments industriels ou les logements
individuels la bible site un charpentier
mythique de l'antiquité dans la personne
de noé beaucoup plus tard on lit
toujours dans la bible que joseph père
de jésus de nazareth était charpentier
nous sommes dans les eaux de l'est dans
la commune de la plaine des palmistes
roland est l'un des derniers anciens
charpentier que compte encore son
village dans ce petit hangar au fond de
sa cour il se rappelle la pure y ait un
droit
que l'on peut tout à fait à chaque fois
d'un fraudeur hydraulique barchane du 6
mai les nanos millions déjà de nadia
tiffy et du dénuement graffiti la peau
la première entreprise gabala mais n'y
ont rien changé
le promu maître
roland a passé près de 60 années de sa
vie entouré de ses outils rudimentaires
auparavant presque tous façonnage se
faisait manuellement comment la moelle
de mes propres yeux comment les
appareils mobiles dit mais bon ça chante
en mitraillant crohot
1809 en grand bassin faites-la cadres
comme un point et moins longtemps mais
les gens racontent des mails on nous
laissait passer à la machine les
penguins mais même si chacune est allé
battre toute âme
il faut
ou allemagne
et des anecdotes le vieil homme ne
manquez pas à cette époque moi quand mon
vieux papa voilà ils travailler mais il
faut un niveau
mounawah niveau le dit de lui qu il y
avait un niveau mais le niveau le tube
en aluminium membres ont ferraillé en
bois
aujourd'hui à la retraite roland a
transmis sa passion qu'il a lui-même
hérité de son père à son fils fabrice
c'est une histoire de famille et je
dirais
moi dans le bois je suis tombé dedans
quand j'étais petit donc j'ai grandi
avec ça mon grand père était charpentier
réaliser mon pea fait le même métier
or plus la suite le charpentier mais
aussi menuisier palmiplainois réalise la
chance qu'il a de travailler dans des
conditions moins pénible que ses aïeux
elle n'est pas que j'avais pas de décès
site et donc il n'y avait pas de machine
je dirais heureusement ça évolue mais
sinon c'était vraiment pénible non moins
grand
mais voilé avec les machines à l'idée
qu'on puisse romain je veux tu qu'on
mesure entendu été
dépeint un travail pénible podium mais
qu'en dit nous le travail était pénible
quand la chine c'est une pièce d'un
ciseau avec un bateau maillé
dans notre xxième siècle le charpentier
réalise et pose des assemblages
participants la constitution de
l'immeuble ou maisons dont les
composantes sont la charpente et
l'ossature générale même si dans le
bâtiment les crises sont fréquentes
fabrice assure le charpentier reste un
métier d'avenir ce que je vois il ya
toujours le jeune relève vraiment il ya
des jeunes qui sont surmotivées mais
il y aura toujours du travail
dans ce métier
la donne à moi